[Musique]
nous sommes ici en face de la cathédrale
notre dame de paris et nous avons en
face de nous un très beau visage
mais ce n'est pas la première chose que
j'ai vue en arrivant à paris il ya trois
ans je dois dire que mon premier contact
avec paris a été plutôt maussade
je me souviens encore de ma descente
d'avion de selon couleurs métalliques
des escalators métallique et je me suis
dit je tombe dans un monde métalliques
dans un monde de béton
et je me rappelle encore de ma première
arrivée là où je devais être accueilli
comme l'avion est en retard je n'étais
plus attendre il était 21h passé et je
sonne n'y avait plus personne je me
plais skier dans une cabine téléphonique
et je tombe sur un répondeur automatique
qui me dit et bien rappeler demain
votre message sera transmis
je me suis dit finalement je tombe dans
un monde inhumain un monde mécanique un
monde technique à moins de btan à moins
de répondeur automatique
[Applaudissements]
mais heureusement pour moi j'ai eu
l'occasion dé découvrir plus tard que à
travers ce manque de boutons à travers
ce monde de mécanique et tout le monde
le métallique à travers même ces visages
figés dans le métro dans le bus eh bien
il ya autre chose il a des possibilités
de contacts et je sais que je découvre
de plus en plus depuis que je suis dans
la paroisse saint louis en l'île où
j'exerce
capitalisme à famille impérialisme
hatami en picardie america latina pour
la mise aux derniers
majeurs gagnés
à la taille elle indiqué
colonialisme un tamis capitalisme hatami
et perial ismat amis africains si
america latina bookeen amap et
[Musique]
canadiennes et bob
gainey à tabanou
[Musique]
dans le cadre de mes études bibliques
j'ai un cours d'archéologie
et de la palestine mais ce cours
d'écologie la palestine a pas donné le
goût donc les études archéologiques
ainsi je viens d'en visiter les sites
archéologiques
comme ce clip de notre dame qui ne
montre le vieux paris qui ne montre pas
raide et un temps
[Musique]
d'accompagnement
et pourquoi bissau
[Musique]
notamment sabine accompagnant ma maman
salines hamid addou est plus loin à
bisseuil la gagne
[Musique]
nous trouvons ici à la place saint
sulpice
c'est ici que j'ai descendu du bus
chaque matin où chaque après-midi
lorsque je me rends à l'insu catholique
pour mes études
ce qui explique en effet ma présence ici
à paris ce sont les études bibliques et
théologiques
et je suis venu poursuivre ici
en ce moment je suis en 3e cycle
d'études bibliques et théologiques
et je travaille plus particulièrement
sur le livre de l'apocalypse
le livre de l'apocalypse est le dernier
livre de la bible c'est un livre
énigmatique
mais en même temps aussi passionnant
pourquoi avoir choisi de travailler sur
l'apocalypse
et c'est surtout parce que pour ma
maîtrise de théologie j'ai travaillé sur
les mouvements prophétique africains les
mouvements prophétique africains sont
nés pour la plupart au moment de
l'indépendance plus tôt avant les
indépendances pendant la période de la
colonisation
un peu comme une réplique d'une part à
la colonisation et d'autre part à un
christianisme qui venait donc l'occident
et ses mouvements politiques ont voulu
d'une part
donner une autre manière de vivre le
christianisme qui sont africaines et de
plus par lutter contre la colonisation
et ses mouvements prophétique en
particulièrement prisé dans l'apocalypse
disons la sof
leur message
[Musique]
la procurer les lieux où je viens me
ravitailler en livres pour mes études de
théologie biblique et quand vous le
voyez sur la vitrine bien les études de
livres bibliques et théologiques comme
et servent pour pour mes études
[Musique]
ma famille impérialisme hatami afrique
asie amérique latine à fond quand
l'habit souvient l'an dernier
mabaya la
gadoue sis au quartier saint michel
c'est un des quartiers que je fréquente
très souvent je viens à me détendre
et je viens particulièrement pour voir
le film
est un des cinémas que je suis content
c'est le cinéma saint-andré-des-arts
parce que c'est un cinéma qui projette
souvent des films africains
pour moi qui suis à paris il est très
important que je reste en contact avec
tout ce que ces vies tout ce qui se
cherche en afrique ce soit sur le point
de vue théologique
économique politique ou culturelle
nous savons en effet que l'afrique en ce
moment et comme à la croisée des chemins
elle cherche à construire son avenir en
tenant compte et de son passé et du
présent d'aujourd'hui et dans cette
recherche de la construction d'une
afrique nouvelle et bien tout le monde
est concerné les artistes des
politiciens les économistes des
théologiens est donc important que je
sois au courant de tout ce qui se
cherche dans c'est ainsi qu'aujourd'hui
sur tous les plans
bonjour comment allez vous ça va très
bien je peux avoir raflé comme
d'habitude
à travers une du soleil parce que c'est
tellement beau h à céret
sportif
maintenant besoin de
ça en ce moment vous l'avez parcours est
un peu oui je crois qu'il veut vraiment
ça une rentrée sans un cadre qui fait
toujours des siennes
tchad sénégal la mauritanie
tout le monde est là
alors je dis bonne semaine bonne journée
enfin en fin de semaine bonne journée
merci au revoir au revoir
[Applaudissements]
je viens d'acheter jeune afrique
à la librairie le plaisir du texte c'est
un des lieux que je fréquente de plus
vous comprenez 7 9 ans pourquoi je viens
souvent mieux habiter ici en lecture
pour la semaine et le vendredi
particulièrement je viens pour acheter
le jeune afrique pour avoir de nouvelles
fraîches du pays pourra pas rester en
contact avec leurs machines
[Applaudissements]
c'est un renault plus forte à part ça je
vienne 2
bonne journée d'accord bourse
[Musique]
et nous sommes une vidéo solitaire
seniors ville s'est essayée moyens
d'accueil c'était c'est que j'habitais
que je travaille
[Musique]
et c'est pour moi bien sûr les études
c'est bien sûr toutes les activités
culturelles les rencontres avec les amis
tous les autres c'est la vie dans l'île
saint louis mais paris c'est aussi et
surtout ma vie de prêtre en effet je
suis prêtre depuis cinq ans j'ai été
pardonné au congo il ya cinq ans et en
arrivant à paris pour poursuivre mes
études théologiques
j'ai été intégré à cette communauté
chrétienne de lille sans lui pour
pouvoir justement continuer à vivre ma
vie de prêtre avec cette paroisse et
l'église saint louis en l'île est un de
ces lieux où je rencontre la communauté
chrétienne
quotidiennement et hebdomadairement
c'est un des lieux où je me retrouve
pour célébrer et prier avec cette
communauté chrétienne de saint louis en
l'île
et la paroisse saint louis en l'île
c'est pour moi l'occasion de rencontrer
comme plâtre africains une communauté
chrétienne européenne française et de
partager ce que je suis moi complète
africain avec une communauté chrétienne
française et aussi surtout l'occasion de
partager à travers l'équipe de prêtres
dans laquelle j'ai intégré de partager
ce qu'ils se complètent
africain avec des prêts de français et
je vous assure que c'est une expérience
riche enrichissante et très intéressante
[Musique]